hello and welcome to drive with the dw
car show coming up a porsche 356 with
almost a million miles on the clock
ford's sporty new focus rs
and volvo's latest xc90 suv
car tester sasha knope describes gili
automobile's acquisition of the volvo
brand from ford in 2010 as a last minute
rescue
at first the new ownership constellation
did not seem to bode well but after
three years the chinese car and
motorcycle makers nearly 10 billion euro
investment program is starting to
produce results like the latest xc90
the updated model introduces a new
design vocabulary our car tester tanju
gench inspects the swedish carmaker's
new flagship inside and out
in norse mythology thor is the god of
thunder overflowing with masculinity and
strength he says the hammer and those
qualities are reflected in the new xc90
like here in the headlights for instance
he wants to look at what the swedish
brand has to offer in its new design
the distinctive new grille and t-shaped
led daytime running lights give the suv
a confident air a face that in future is
to grace all of volvo's models the
elegant and luxurious package of extras
is called the inscription
even with the changes great and small
from the back the xc90 is unmistakably
of oval
tanju notices quite a few changes in the
model's interior there's a digital
instrument cluster and a 22.8 inch head
up touch screen display embedded in
volvo's trademark center console all the
functions can be controlled via this
display
volvo appears to have borrowed a few
ideas from electric car manufacturer
tesla motors the tablet style display
gives easy access to all the cars
options and settings
along the bottom of the center console
is a row of seven buttons and a dial
the sound system has also been
thoroughly reworked
that if you've ever wanted to experience
a concert hall in gothenburg now you can
just do it in an xc90
19 bowers and wilkins speakers are
installed and the concert hall option
activates them
all a glance at the specs reveals that
even after downsizing from a six to a
four cylinder engine the volvo xc90
still got plenty of power
the t6 we tested sends 235 kilowatts to
its all-wheel drive propelling the
vehicles two tons from zero to a hundred
kilometers per hour in six and a half
seconds technology tester sasha knopf
checked out the safety features
he says the new xc90 has made some
advances in terms of safety it's got for
instance a new driver's assist that
senses if the car runs off the road this
isn't a lane departure warning it
actually works passively it activates an
electronic belt tightener that keeps the
seat belt firmly tightened during an
accident he says many other systems use
a pressurized gas chamber
once it's empty the tension on the seat
belt lets up very rapidly but this
electronic belt tightener keeps the
tension up the entire time the vehicle
is
runoff road protection is standard on
the new xc90 the moment the sensors
detect the car leaving the asphalt the
front seat belts are tightened
electronically as far as they'll go and
kept that way until the vehicle comes to
a standstill
sasha says he's also had the opportunity
to drive the xc90s t8 version which is
the plug-in hybrid it puts out 294
kilowatts of power but carries a hefty
price tag over 76 000 euros for that it
promises both sportiness and
environmental friendliness now he's
going to take a look
the t8 is the top of the line xc90 with
just two and a half liters of fuel per
100 kilometers this beefy suv puts out
294 kilowatts of power but produces just
59 grams of co2 per kilometer
a touch of class in the interior is the
shift lever made of crystal glass
design tester tanju gench sums up
the xc90 has evolved the front is new
but the rear is typical for volvo he
liked the design but not the price but
at least he gets something good for the
money
the suv meets everyone's needs looks
good and offers the safety features
expected of oval and what's sasha knop's
impression
he says the xc60 was the best-selling
mid-range suv in 2014 and this new xc90
met all his expectations all in all he
thinks things are looking up for volvo
and the run-up to the unveiling ceremony
for its new rs ford ruled out the red
carpet for the cars forbearers
visitors to the car makers facility in
cologne loved it
the first rs was built in cologne says
stila merka the car maker launched the
15 mrs and the 17 mrs in 1967.
telos club is happy to have the chance
to present cars from the model's history
the first of those two models featured a
55 kilowatt 1.7 liter engine with a
paint job sporting racing stripes
but it was body details in the 17 mrs
that would define the special model's
look its standard v6 engine packs 66
kilowatts of power but customers could
also opt for a racier 79 kilowatt
version
inside the dash and dials emphasize the
car's sporty image
says the first motors were powerful but
conventional later ford introduced turbo
engines fuel injection and four-wheel
drive special rally racing technologies
and ford brought them to the street
the brand first brought out a street
legal rally style car in the 1960s
because of its grill the escort rs was
fondly known as the dog
bone the rs 200 was an extreme example
of ford's technology transfer developed
for group b rally races its huge air
intake scoops fed a mid-mounted engine
what rule changes force designers to
return to more conventional vehicles the
focus became a rally car but even the
street legal rs pulled a respectable 154
kilowatts out of four cylinders its
successor also a front-wheel drive
vehicle was a real eye-catcher drivers
could call audits up to 500 newton
meters of torque when necessary
amateur racer frog freudzime says this
car still has its original five-cylinder
motor and to handle it you have to watch
the rpms and torque that means you can
either torque it up close to the red
line or shift early and pick up speed
through torque when you accelerate
ford started the countdown to the
official launch of the latest generation
rs with a surprise appearance the
prototype was piloted over the
carmaker's factory grounds by rally
racer and internet phenomenon ken block
on the way to the presentation it was
his job to show off how well the car
handles even when pushed to the limit by
maneuvering past some expensive
obstacles
it was a final test for the new rs which
looks set to find a new fan base outside
the sport as well guests were impressed
the pro was too
well i mean i'm very happy that ford uh
has developed you know the rs again
brought the heritage back to the rs
brand uh but on top of that developing
it with all-wheel drive and more
horsepower uh you know than they have in
the past is amazing so it's been really
cool to be a part of the development
process on such a very good car
the audience got a look at what the new
top of the line focus can do but only
saw the final design after it had been
put through its paces that's when ford
pulled off the wrapping paper on the new
compact made in cologne
the look is radical for the car maker
ford design manager ernesto rupar says
the focus rs was developed here in
cologne but the overall design was a
joint effort with the ford performance
team in detroit
performance is everything in the compact
sports car segment cooling aerodynamics
and technology have to be top notch
the model's head engineer says its motor
which is the same as the mustangs has a
2.3 liter ecoboost it's been
fundamentally altered and adapted in the
rs it was implemented in conjunction
with the all-wheel drive of course he
says
that ladder feature appears to have been
made for ken block's extreme driving
style he's glad ford has implemented the
change
so i've been pushing that for that for
years and uh ford really listened and
and listened to not only me though but
the customers that the customers wanted
that too
so
really you know that initial development
of the all-wheel drive and the idea that
was uh something i i was able to help
with
and since then i've been able to
help with the
you know the testing and tuning of the
uh the all-wheel drive system and the
suspension so that's mainly what i've
been involved with
in combination with the car maker's
torque vectoring technology the
all-wheel drive can distribute up to 70
percent of the engine's 235 kilowatts of
output to the rear wheels and up to 100
percent of that to the outside wheel in
a curve so lateral acceleration of up to
1g poses no problem
hungry fans will have to be patient
though it's still unclear exactly when
the new rs will hit the market
mercedes is adding sporty amg models to
its c-class stable top of the line is
the c63 amg powered by a 350 kilowatt v8
engine
the s version boasts 25 kilowatts more
power
other special features include an amg
sports suspension with three-stage
adjustable damping and a locking rear
differential
the leon st cooper is seatt's sporty new
station wagon the model is available
with a choice of 195 or 206 kilowatt
engines when fitted with the heftier
power plant the leon st cupra can charge
from zero to 100 kilometers an hour in
just six seconds yet the car also offers
a generous
1470 liters of cargo space
car tester chris kestia says this is a
very special golf the e-golf with
electric drive only it has no
gasoline-powered engine so it isn't a
hybrid he's going to be testing the car
in ice and snow
the volkswagen golf has been a fixture
on streets the world over for 40 years
now but this is the first purely
electric model and it completes the car
makers range of powertrains
many other car makers developed their
electric vehicles as separate models and
built them in separate plants but not vw
the e-golf looks just like a
conventional golf and it's produced
right alongside its gasoline-powered
piers in wolfsburg
chris says the e-golf is a proper golf
it's just as uncluttered and spacious as
the gasoline-powered models the only
difference is in the dashboard display
which is of course geared to electric
drive
the electric gulf's interior is
virtually identical to that of a
conventional gulf
under the hood the electric motor hums
along
depending on the route driving style
load and outside temperature the e-golf
can range between 130 and
kilometers on a charge the electric
motor achieves 85 kilowatts and a
maximum 270 newton meters of torque
right from a standstill and his
performance on the road is quite
satisfactory there are no gears the
motor accelerates evenly up to its 140
kilometer an hour limit
chris points out another big advantage
of the electric vw the trunk is spacious
the cargo space's 305 liters is just as
much as in the gasoline and
diesel-powered golf models
that's because the batteries are built
into the floor and tunnel
and when the driver hits the brakes the
electric motor recuperates energy and
recharges the batteries
different settings or regen levels are
available to determine how much the
motor can be used to break the car
a gauge in the cockpit tells the driver
exactly how much energy is flowing back
into the batteries
three driver selectable levels
coordinate the interaction of the motor
and the braking system
chris confirms that even at below
freezing the e-golf has a good range in
the eco plus mode more than 130
kilometers per charge
it may look like a regular golf on the
outside but the inside is packed with
high-tech only a few details on the body
betray its presence
the shuttered blue striped grille and
especially designed rims identify the
e-golf streamline the vehicle to
increase range
the e-golf can be connected to any
outlet
and it can be recharged to eighty
percent capacity at public charging
stations in 30 minutes
chris sums up that with a relatively
limited range of 150 kilometers the
e-golf is best suited to urban driving
this is for car shoppers looking for an
emissions free and comfortable ride but
at a starting price of 35 000 euros it's
not the cheapest
spring is in the air the perfect season
for bmw to launch the successor to its
one series convertible the two series
convertible is just over seven
centimeters longer than its predecessor
but it's retained the brand's typical
proportions with little overhang a long
hood long wheelbase and broad toe
product manager paloma schmidt brakling
says what really sets the car apart from
its forebear is the discrete design
larger dimensions and enhanced luxury
the silhouette is longer with flat
shoulders and a very small rear that's
why it handles great and looks so sporty
she says even when parked
since its introduction in 2008 130 000
units of the one series compact
convertible have been sold the 2 series
convertible is flatter and longer than
the 1 series 3 and 5 door models
roll bars are hidden inside the
headrests and back and a new
construction material has gone into the
car's retractable roof
paloma says bmw was able to reduce
ambient noise by five to seven decibels
by adding insulation
the soft top can be opened and closed in
just 20 seconds at speeds up to 50
kilometers an hour
so you don't have to pull over just to
put the top up or down a nice feature it
means you can react almost instantly to
sudden changes in weather with the top
down the new model also has 20 more
liters of volume in the trunk than its
predecessor for more cargo space owners
can lower the rear seats
our test car was fitted with the brand
sportline interior it includes accents
like red seats red seams on the steering
wheel and red highlights on the door
panels
customers can also choose from the
advantage luxury line or m sport
packages
our car sports the 228i inline
four-cylinder gasoline engine that packs
180 kilowatts the automatic transmission
eases up to 100 kilometers an hour in
six seconds and top speed of
250. the new 2-series convertible has
already gone on sale in german
dealerships now the weather just has to
play along
classic cars always turn heads
most people love to look at vintage
vehicles and a lucky few have the
pleasure of owning one
but even fewer drive theirs around every
day and draw plenty of envious glances
guy newmark from california is one of
those lucky people for close to half a
century he's been tooling around in this
1964 porsche
356c porsche
that uh my family's owned almost since
new
my dad got it uh
i guess
about
a month
after it was brought here to the united
states then he drove it for
three or four years
and gave it to me when i graduated from
college and we've been inseparable
everywhere i go i'm with blue
blue isn't just any old car it's guy
newmark's constant companion
blue has a
900 about 992 000 miles now
um
when i received blue it had a little
under 80 000. my dad had put that on it
76 or 77 thousand and i put all the rest
on
twenty thousand
miles a year that i put on the car
before taking over his father's yacht
business guy was his dad's right hand
man
back in the days before email and fax
machines guy had to travel to his
customers to do business
sometimes he drove clear across the u s
it was then that he developed his close
relationship with blue
and the car has held a special place in
his heart to this day
i love the color
the color is just magnificent it's bali
blue it's original porsche color we
haven't changed it at all
and
the other
thing is that when you're driving a 356
uh you're really driving a car
there's no special handling there's no
uh
you know gift of any mechanical you're
you're driving a car and when i talk to
people that have driven 356s
and they've sold them
every person 100 have said i'm really
sorry i sold my 356 because it's such an
exhilarating driving experience
since 1971 blue has shared the garage
with another porsche 356 a red 1962
convertible but blue remains guy's
favorite
so it's the original engine we've
rebuilt it twice
and matter of fact this last month we
just did valves and
went through the engine cad plated
everything we did rings new muffler and
blue's ready for another million miles
now
i think the secret is wonderful
engineering
um
and that combined with
proper maintenance
it is a mechanical item you do have to
maintain it and i'm pretty religious
about
changing the oil and taking care of it
and having the valves adjusted
another secret to blue's longevity is
the magnet affixed to the oil filter it
catches any metal particles that pass
through the filter and prevents them
from entering the engine compartment
guy also had the interior completely
refurbished although that was over
twenty five years ago
everything was restored to its original
condition
only the lamb's wool seat covers are the
owner's private touch
the old 356 seize odometer only goes up
to 99
999 miles but guy plans to be driving
blue for a long while to come
blue's a buddy
i've been living with blue for almost 50
years so blue blue's a friend i talk to
blue all the time i just i'm in real
trouble if blue talks back to me
he loves the porsche but guy hasn't
always been faithful
well i bought another car
and i bought that car so i wouldn't have
to drive blue every day in case it was
raining or i just didn't want to drive
blue and the very first day i drove that
car on the freeway i was rear-ended and
pushed into the back of a truck and the
car was totaled
and i think it was blue saying what the
hell are you doing
and so i would drive blue every day
wherever i go no matter what the weather
is
blue's odometer shows that the porsche
has so far traveled 990
823 miles or around 1 594
575 kilometers
that's the equivalent of rounding the
globe almost forty times or traveling to
the moon and back twice
the car still has nine thousand miles to
go to crack the million mark but after
fifty years on the road blue is still
going strong and shows no sign of
slowing down
next time on drive it join us as we
check out skoda's new fabia station
wagon
and see what's new for spring at the
geneva motor show
you